what is going on guys it's killer ginger
here and before you do anything and
before i start the top of the video i
just wish they think clicking on the
video i'm new to youtube this is my
first video on the channel and probably
ready tell what the title so thank you
for clicking on the video really means a
lot to me but let's just get into it so
where do I start well 16 I'm still in
high school so don't be expecting daily
videos from me I'd like to crank out
videos hopefully once a week that'd be
nice maybe two if I can get the gameplay
footage just like you're seeing
overwatch here in the gameplay I'll see
yeah not exactly the greatest with the
software at the moment still trying to
figure out with the kinks of it I'll get
that down with hopefully within the next
month or two I hope let's see next is
gameplay and what I'm going to be doing
on this channel terms of the content on
this channel will probably be gaming
maybe a montage very rarely a montage
maybe gaming stuff I can rant about you
know if I don't if I'm bringing up a
certain topic on a game or not other
than that I would just like to thank you
for clicking on this video once again it
really means a lot to me thing is my
first youtube video I just remember to
make sure to LIKE comment your opinion
if you're if you're new subscribe and I
will see you later enjoy the gameplay
peace
come get your armor feeling boo
he's at first you don't succeed pull out
up again headin stablished thanks mate
Oh
I
big time
you